what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
we have some great news in the Marvel
Universe world today they have done test
screenings for the Marvels the upcoming
Captain Marvel 2 film and it seems like
Marvel Studios is getting back on track
to once again consistently making great
projects you may have caught my secret
Invasion review if you haven't go ahead
and check it out it is spoiler free so
no spoilers but I truly did enjoy the
first two episodes that I've seen so far
I did I really loved it and I thought
just the quality of the writing the
story everything was really really good
and it sounds like that is what we
should expect for the Marvels also in
this video we'll talk about Spider-Man
4. it looks like we could have an
official release date for Spider-Man 4.
and if you haven't heard about the
recent Hulk Solo movie rights we'll
break that down in this video as well so
if you love Marvel and you want to stay
up to date be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification Bell we're also doing
a giveaway we'll talk about that at the
so if you are unaware Disney and Marvel
Studios and most of the studios out
there before they release the films and
before they finalize the final version
of films they do test screenings now
Disney and in turn Marvel Studios have
recently come out and kind of told us
about their process for this they do
test screenings and basically what
happens is employees of Disney of the
studio get sent emails asking if they
want to see a movie they are not told
which specific movie that they are going
to be seen this is what they try to do
so they can try to avoid bias because if
they sent out an email that said hey we
invite you to a very very advanced
screening of the Marvels there are
people out there who love Miss Marvel
who love Captain Marvel who love Monica
Rambo's character who are gonna go and
be very excited to watch this screening
and they're probably going to say very
great things about it because they love
the character so this way it does avoid
that bias towards it and it makes what
people say about the test screening back
to the studio very real now normal Lee
well in fact usually most of the time
you're not allowed to say anything you
sign an NDA a non-disclosure agreement
and it states hey whatever you see you
absolutely cannot say anything about and
if we find out that you did we sue you
now nothing has really come out about
the movie's specifics like any of the
plot details however the reactions from
some people we know what they said
thanks to some insiders who have sources
that have seen these test screenings we
are hearing this from two insiders
viewer a non and big screen leaks both
have great track records and the first
tweet came from big screen leak stating
so viewer Anon just told me something
and I swear if he is messing with me I
will cause chaos across the land and we
soon find out why that is viewer Anon
replied to that tweet stating the
Marvels had a public test screening last
night all the usual roles apply it's one
audience early in the process take with
a grain of salt Etc but I heard it went
well the audience seemed to enjoy it as
did all of my sources so again keep in
mind those rules that I was talking
about before the movie is not not
completely finished yet so what they saw
is not going to be the final version of
the film and the film doesn't come out
until November but their feedback does
help Marvel Studios know what the
audience likes or doesn't like and this
can help push the film in a better
direction to where the movie is actually
better itself so right now if you are
excited for the Marvels and I know a lot
of people are then you should remain
excited to see the Marvels because it
sounds like it's already pretty good and
can only get better from here and I do
think based off of what we've seen so
far it does look like it's going to be a
pretty good movie in Marvel Studios I
think recently has upped their game with
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 and secret
Invasion I know the critics ratings for
it right now aren't that good but
everybody else that I've talked to that
is a true Marvel fan that has seen it
already Chris over at Cosmic culture
Greg over at the real rejects everybody
is literally saying that they love it
not that it's good that they love it so
I think Marvel Studios is on that path
of getting back to hitting Banger after
Banger after Banger and speaking of that
one of the bangers that I know a lot
about us are really looking forward to
is that rumored World War Hulk movie and
boy do we have some big news about that
if you've heard the news let me explain
what exactly it means and if you haven't
you are in for a treat there have been
talks about the rights to the Hulk
specifically about the rights to use the
Hulk in a Solo movie reverting back to
Marvel Studios if you are not aware
Universal had that right for a very long
time Marvel and Disney were allowed to
use the Hulk and team up and group films
but never just a solo Hulk film that is
why we have not had a solo Hulk film in
an extremely long time but rumors of a
World War Hulk film being in development
starring just our Hulk Mark Ruffalo have
been going around for a long time now
and people were wondering well how could
this happen if Universal has the rights
to a solo Hulk film but then reports and
rumors came out stating that well
actually those rights went back to
Marvel Studios and now we finally have a
report to confirm this has actually
happened Marvel Studios doesn't indeed
have the rights to make a solo Hulk film
now and they absolutely can so bring on
World War Hulk this is coming from a
report from variety with a report titled
Incredible Hulk is finally coming to
Disney Plus in which you can now watch
that movie on Disney plus and then they
say the Incredible Hulk is smashing its
way to Disney Plus on June 16th the
streamer announced Thursday and the
second paragraph States this the film
was initially released and distributed
by Universal on June 13th of 2008 and
the company held the rights to the title
for 15 years now and a notable shift the
rights have reverted to Marvel Studios
leading to the film's release on Disney
plus so Marvel Studios does now
officially have the rights to the Hulk
so that world war Hulk project that
we've been hearing about is coming now
how they're going to adapt that we don't
really know at this point in time we
don't think it's going to be like the
comic iteration of it but from what we
know it is going to start the story it's
going to start developing in Captain
America Brave New World with Thunderball
Ross experimenting with the serum and
hopefully fingers crossed him turning
into Red Hulk we'll have to wait and see
on the official story but the great news
is Marvel Studios can make it happen now
we are going to be getting a solo Hulk
movie and to top it off it looks like
Sony has given us a release date for
both Venom 3 and Spider-Man 4 it would
appear according to deadline.com Sony
has just reserved the dates for Untitled
Sony Marvel movies for November 8th of
2024 and June 27th of 2025 both will
have access to IMAX screens and the
speculation is that Venom 3 could be for
that first slot November 8th of 2024 and
Tom Holland's next Spider-Man movie
could be for June 27th of 2025. now the
first release date being for Venom 3
makes sense we already knew it was going
to come out sometime around October and
Halloween of 2024 so the November
release date makes sense and then as far
as June 27th of 2025 being for
Spider-Man 4 that pretty much fits
perfectly Sony and Marvel Studios and
Tom Holland himself have come out and
said yeah they have met about Spider-Man
4 they're working on it right now it's
gonna happen and based off the
trajectory of everything happening right
now this release date makes a lot of
sense plus it is coming out before the
King Dynasty since the King Dynasty got
pushed back a year and is now coming out
on May 1st of 2026. that means Tom
Holland Spider-Man is going to be able
to wrap up his story as far as everybody
not knowing who he is as far as MJ Ned
if he returns doctor strange and More
Heroes he is now going to have time
before the King Dynasty happens because
we know he's going to be one of the
leads of it to wrap up his story in a
way where the Avengers basically know
who he is again and yes they do still
know of Spider-Man but they don't know
that Peter Parker is Spider-Man we'll
have to wait and see what they decide on
for the story Tom Holland said the story
sounds great so far so we're excited
already for it but it does look like
June 27th of 22 25 is going to be our
Spider-Man 4 release date so let us know
how excited you are about all of this
news in the comments down below the
Marvel's test screenings the rights
going back to Marvel Studios For The
Hulk and are Spider-Man 4 release date
don't forget to like the video and if
you subscribe and leave a comment you're
entered in our giveaway for a chance to
win an Xbox series X A PS5 some Marvel
Legends items and some DC items as well
winner gets to pick one item and we pick
a winner at the end of each month also
we're now on a patreon we have a website
that we post to every day and we have a
Discord server if you want to join that
we'll link those in the pin comment
don't forget to follow us on Instagram
and Twitter as well and as always thank
you all so much for watching wolf wolf